[Musique]
le baromètre en fait l'objectif c'était
de dresser un état des lieux de l'état
de la démocratie dans notre département
on voulait voir comment fonctionnait la
démocratie représentative comment elle
ne fonctionnait pas et ça a été
l'objectif de de ce
baromètre donc on a
interview finalement 120 élus
d'opposition du département ont répondu
à à ce omètre ils sont issus de 54
communes ce qui représente quand même
plus de 40 % des communes des communes
concernées par par cette
démarche on a un observatoire de la la
conjoncture un observatoire français de
la conjoncture économique on a un
observatoire de la la biodiversité et en
matière de démocratie assez bizarrement
dans le pays des Lumières dans le pays
des libertés des droits de l'homme on
n'a pas véritablement de dispositif
d'observation de la démocra ocratie
locale et c'est dommage parce que si ce
ce dispositif existait réellement ça
permettrait effectivement d'identifier
quelles sont les bonnes pratiques mais
également d'identifier quelles sont les
mesures qui peuvent être prises pour
améliorer un système aujourd'hui qui est
quand même à bout de
souffle on démissionne quatre fois plus
proportionnellement dans les rangs de
l'opposition que dans les rangs de de de
la majorité et après les autres chiffres
qui qui qui expliquent cette situation
bah c'est c'est finalement que les élus
d'opposition 95 % d'entre eux nous
disent que leurs propositions sont pas
écouté par le maire 87 % qui nous disent
que quand ils font des demandes
d'information ils ont difficilement ils
obtiennent difficilement une réponse
positive de la part du maire donc on a
un vrai problème de de de
[Musique]
fonctionnement la suite c'est justement
d'aller rencontrer euh les
parlementaires de rencontrer
euh y compris le préfet dans les
prochaines semaines pour mettre en en
avant parce que dans le baromètre on a
aussi identifié des non respects de la
réglementation aujourd'hui je vais vous
en citer un c'est le droit d'accès à aux
outil de communication numérique dans
les communes et donc là il y a il y a il
y a une nécessité d'intervention du
préfet pour faire en sorte que il puisse
y avoir accès c'est la
loi